I'm ready what do you think huh um no no
this is not a gym this is like a singing
out of saw five you haven't even looked
around yet
look gravel bucket squat yoke right
dedicated phone book ripping station you
ever cut tin before no five yards in and
your forearms will be on fire plus I
will buy the tin back from you that you
cut for two cents a yard now let's go
over membership I'm gonna need the first
months and the last month's up front for
$49 a month but every third month is $59
a month but the fourth month is discount
month and $19 per month obviously said
you know how a gym works so you know I'm
not gonna pay money for this when people
come in your gym make a real gym Darryl
Dunder Mifflin Dwight Schrute please
hold
Schrute farms gutentag how can I help
you yes we have availability on those
nights how many in your party oh no I'm
sorry no king beds no queen either well
we make our own mattresses that don't
conform to the traditional sizes closest
would be twin thank you so much for
calling call back again I'll feed the
same anyway none your business Jim you
running a bed-and-breakfast is not a B&B
agritourism is a lot more than a
bed-and-breakfast it consists of
tourists coming to a farm showing them
around giving them a bed giving them
breakfast does the Department of Health
I am not telling you anything
permits are pending Dwight Schrute
Dunder Mifflin okay this is a misuse of
company phones it says here you cater to
the elderly where did you read that
TripAdvisor TripAdvisor is the lifeblood
of Agri tourism industry a couple of bad
reviews there you may as well close up
shop that's what took down the stock in
one of the cutest little asparagus farms
you'll ever see how many in your party
too we offer our tours of the fields and
of the barn perhaps you'd be interested
in moses table-making demonstration to
white why is the toilet paper only half
apply I'm sorry is that not good enough
for your anus
don't get me started on how coddled the
modern anus is okay um Stanley maybe you
can just unspool a little more each time
you need to don't tell me how to do my
business Stanley as a fellow Dunder
Mifflin employee I feel for you but like
you I am completely powerless to the
whims of the new building owner which is
U which is U is not a sentence I
disagree with are you gonna just sit
there office administrator are you gonna
do something
do I can we talk about these cutbacks
Pam when I'm sitting at this desk I'm a
Salesman
if you want to talk to the new building
owner you should call Nate and schedule
an appointment I'm not gonna do that
well then you're not gonna talk to the
new building owner which is a shame
because I hear he's a very reasonable
guy
Yello hi Nate its Pam Halpert oh hey I
would just love to schedule a meeting
today with Dwight sure Dwight Schrute
mm-hmm tell her I'm busy Hey Dwight's
being questioned by the police in
connection with a string of dognappings
Dwight Dwight can you please tell new
building owner that he is screwing over
all the people he works with people he's
worked with for years his friends you
know what Pam you're right
this isn't just a business this is a
home and I would much rather see a smile
from Kevin than save hundreds on
plumbing and electricity hello welcome
to hey place a place for hey don't
forget to make a broom oh the petting
zoo closes at 2:00 and the goat roast is
at 3:00 come on in enjoy hey I'm kind of
in the mood for a roll in a roll in the
hay $5.00
no I meant Oh
a contract yeah yes why don't we meet at
the usual spot I've got a half an hour
during lunch in between the historical
reenactment another Dunmore farm
slaughters and the onion boil perfect so
excuse me get off in there those are
show bales not play bales
hey kids with that fun alright I bet you
do
you know what when I was a little kid
they couldn't get me off the hayride and
it's gonna cost you three more bucks Wow
this brings back memories
hey stacking hay throwing and at the end
of it all one lucky boy would be crowned
hey king
I always wanted to be a king the world
shines on Mose and now by show of
applause we will crown this year's hay
king
all in favor of purebred put your hands
together for mixed bred and let's hear
it for purebred appear to have a
three-way tie I have no choice but to
pick the hay king myself I pick me I am
your hay King all hail your hay king did
I truck 300 bales of hay to a parking
lot to rectify some childhood
disappointment yes Wow
late every day this week we've signed CC
up for this daycare it's on the other
side of town
the traffic why didn't I think of this
before did you know that there is a
daycare center opening right here in
this building is there really now that I
own the building I'm looking for new
sources of revenue and a daycare center
[Laughter]
well I guess it's not an evil idea it's
just a regular idea but there's no good
laughs for a regular idea
welcome to the Sesame Avenue daycare
center for infants and toddlers remember
my cousin Mose welcome children were you
painting in the dark wait is this your
place tonight
oh no no I like to think of it as the
kids place would you like a tour I don't
think we're really let's take the tour
Pam yeah come on here is the language
skills and cognitive development area
these are English letters I see you
found our magical toy box Jim these are
actually for tonight from the break room
to you and me maybe but come on to a
child's imagination that's mr. fork and
lieutenant knife and Miss Fork and a soy
sauce packet that should have been in
there I'm embarrassed don't beat
yourself up we come fully equipped with
a restroom feeding trough play bucket
and room for a plant in success who will
be watching the children no one the door
locks from the outside escape is
impossible
prove it what we're gonna head outside
let's give it a whirl I just want to see
how it works
oh no no no I don't tell you this if it
works out I promise you that door locks
Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim
Oh anyway I am gonna be your new boss
it's my greatest dream come true welcome
to the hotel hell check-in time is now
checkout time is never does there enough
cable no and the sheets are made of fire
cutting rooms
sorry we're all booked up hell
convention in town
can I have a check out I'll have to talk
to the manager you're not the manager
even in your own fantasy
I'm the owner a co-owner with Satan okay
just so I understand that in your
wildest fantasy
you are in hell and you are Co running a
bed-and-breakfast with the devil
you're gonna haven't told you my salary
yet go $80,000 a year once I am
officially Regional Manager my first
order of business will be to demote Jim
Halpert so I will need a new number two
my ideal choice Jack Bauer but he is
unavailable fictional I'm qualified
you